- Welcome to the show.
It is great to meet you.
-Thanks for having me.
-And congrats on
all the success
of "White Lotus."
Golden Globe awards.
Today, you just got nominated
for a SAG award.
-Yeah.
-This is a big deal.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well-deserved.
-Thanks.
-I'm going to read you a couple
reviews about you here.
-Oh, don't do that.
-Plug your ears.
"USA Today" says,
"Fahy is effervescent,
lighting up every scene
she's in."
-Oh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-"Entertainment Weekly" said,
"Meghann Fahy
is flat-out incredible."
There you go. Come on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You can't get better than that.
-That's so nice.
-You know what is nice, though?
I've been reading articles
about the cast,
and you guys are all friendly
in talking about each other.
And they said that you were
the nicest person
that they worked with
and they said that everyone out
of the cast,
you seem like
the most outgoing person.
-Oh, wow.
-You would talk to everybody
and say hi to everyone.
-Oh, yes, well, that's true.
-Yeah?
-I think it's very important
to, like, sort of know
your neighborhood.
So, when I got to Sicily,
I wanted to make friends
with all the people.
Because it's like, you know,
I'm a New Yorker
and you've got to make friends
with the bodega guy.
-Absolutely.
-My bodega guy
installed my A.C.
-It's part of your neighborhood.
-Exactly.
-Yes.
-So --
-You know bartenders.
-That's right.
You've got to get in.
Yeah.
-Yes.
So, in Sicily, you walked
around, introduced --
you said hi --
-Yeah, I felt like Belle
from "Beauty and the Beast"
sometimes.
I'd be like walking down
the street
with my little basket
full of flowers.
And people would be like
sticking out the shop to say hi.
It's very cute, yeah.
-"Hi, Meghann. Hi."
I heard you also did a cooking
class with one of the --
-Yeah, so I made friends with
the owner of one
of the restaurants.
-This is what happened.
-And I mentioned that
I wanted to take
a cooking class.
And he was like, "Well,
you should come here
and I'll give you one."
And I said, "Okay."
He said, "Just come
at noon tomorrow."
Which also, is like
kind of cool, right?
-Fantastic.
-No texting,
just show up to this place
at 12:00.
-Love Italy, yes.
-Yeah.
So, I went, and then it wasn't
actually a cooking class,
because it just was me
in the kitchen
while the restaurant was open
and serving food.
And I was just sort of
in the kitchen, like --
-Cooking?
-Cleaning things
and serving them to people.
-So, he gave you a job?
-Yeah, I had a chef hat on.
-Wow. You got a job.
-He made me a gin and tonic.
We were --
-Fantastic.
12:00, noon?
-[ Chuckles ] Yeah.
-But this show really
kind of kicks off with you.
No spoilers,
but you discovering a dead body.
And is it a little bit relaxing
knowing that you're not the one
dying at the end of the show?
-Well, I have to tell you,
I read -- I read it.
-Yeah.
-And I was like,
"Okay, this character
finds the body."
But I didn't necessarily
feel like that meant
that I still couldn't
potentially be dead.
You know? Like, because
you just don't know.
-Oh, maybe it's
a dream sequence.
-Yeah, who knows?
-I mean, that's where
my brain goes.
-At first, I was like,
"Oh, cool, I'm alive."
And then I was like,
"Well, let's see.
Let's read the rest
of this first to find out."
-So, you really didn't know?
-Yeah.
-I want to say because
I love Mike White obviously.
-Same.
-I know.
Gosh, who doesn't love the guy?
But in the opening scene,
these two actors
are right there.
And these actually
weren't even really actors.
These are --
-That's right.
-These are -- they were on
"Survivor" with Mike White.
-Yeah. Let's clap for them.
They killed it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
So good.
-Kara Kay and Angelina Keeley.
-Yes.
-Did you watch the "Survivor"
season with Mike White on it?
-I did. I had to.
-Me, too. I loved it.
-I had a couple of friends
who said,
"If you only watch
one episode of 'Survivor,'
it should be this one."
-I agree.
-So, I watched it in Italy.
And then when Mike told me --
because we shot that scene
sort of towards the end.
And when he told me that it was
going to be these two women
that were doing the scene with
me, I was like fan girling.
-And how are they as actors?
-Fantastic.
Angelina might be
the most committed.
-Okay.
-She did cry a lot.
There was one part we were
shooting the body being
sort of pulled from the water.
-Yes.
-And she really went for it.
And Mike was like, "Angelina,
you've got to stop crying."
[ Laughter ]
-Really?
-Yeah.
He was like, "It's not sad.
It's spooky.
You don't know this person."
-[ Laughs ]
-And she was like, "Okay, damn."
[ Laughter ]
But, no, they were amazing.
And I was actually so impressed
with how great they genuinely
were in that scene.
-It all worked perfect,
the casting,
all the way around were
just knockout performances.
When, if you watch this season,
you'll be like,
"Oh, yeah, everyone's great."
But you were unbelievable.
Do you get asked about
the last scene?
I don't want to spoil anything
but --
-But let's spoil it.
-I'm not going to spoil it.
But does anything happen?
Did anything happen?
-Yes. I think so.
-What?
-Yes.
-What?!
-You want me to tell you
what it was?
-What are you talking about?
Roots, play some music
for a little bit.
-Just play some -- anything.
Just, yeah, what happened?
♪♪
You think so?
-Yeah.
-Wow. Alright.
Good. Wow.
-Thanks, guys.
-Wow. Yeah, that was it.
That was the spoiler.
I just heard it.
[ Applause ]
No, she didn't tell me anything.
But do people come up and go,
"Hey, what did --"
Why would people ask?
You shot something
and didn't use it?
That was actually shot, right,
what you did?
-Well, no, it wasn't,
which is what's so cool
about Mike.
I feel like he's really
interested in sort of like...
-The mystery.
-...suggesting something
and then letting
the audience kind of decide
how they feel about it.
Sort of open to interpretation.
So, even -- It was really funny
'cause I saw him
on the night of the finale.
And I asked him, because
people ask me all the time.
-Yeah.
-I was like,
"What do you think happened?"
And I told him
what I thought happened.
-Yeah.
-He was like, "Ew,
I don't want to think
about that."
-Wow.
[ Laughter ]
I hate spoilers, and I don't
know how long you have to wait
to talk about something,
because it's like,
it's out and the ending is out,
but some people don't know
and I don't want to ruin
anything for anyone.
But it is fantastic.
Watch "The White Lotus,"
HBO Max, Meghann Fahy.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Meghann
in "The White Lotus."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Cameron Hartford, why?
-Maybe something happened.
[ Waves crashing ]
[ Indistinct conversations
in distance ]
-I don't think you have
anything to worry about.
I mean, you never really
know what goes on
in people's minds
or what they do, right?
You spend every second
with somebody,
and there's still
this part that's a mystery.
-Yeah! That's how you do it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Meghann Fahy, everybody.
All episodes of season 2
of "The White Lotus"
are available to stream
on HBO Max.
More "Tonight Show"
when we come back.
Stick around, everybody.